ich hatte panik und dann habe ich
gedacht ich muss jetzt wieder ein buch
ganz ganz schlecht finden
und siehe da ich finde es gar nicht
schlecht ich auch nicht witzig ist ein
witziges buch sicher was für frauen über
40 sowie mich und philipp kohl hat ja so
die neigung mich gerne mal zu quälen
indem sie mir in letzten schrei der
deutschen nachwuchs literatur vorschlägt
alle frauen die ungefähr in meinem
jahrgang sind jung
ok mit mitte 40 ist man nur noch junge
mann stirbt dann ist man früh gestorben
und jung gestorben sonst ist man für
nichts eigentlich mehr jungen mit mitte
vierzig foyer das stimmt es ist die
geschichte von zwei freundinnen beide
knapp über 40 die sich gemeinsam
aufmachen um den vater der einen und
freundinnen von hannover aus in die
schweiz zu bringen weil er da
sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen will und
dann stellt sich heraus dass der vater
gar nicht in die schweiz wollte um zu
sterben sondern seine erste große liebe
wieder treffen wenn autoren befassen
sich gerne in ihrer midlife crisis mit
mit sich selbst und hier ist es eine
autorin die das irgendwie ganz anders
angeht sie schreibt über das verhältnis
zu ihren eltern und das ist doch
interessant
dieses buch hat auch etwas was ich ganz
selten in deutschsprachiger literatur
finden nämlich selbstironie er und es
ist einfach auch sehr lustig an ganz
vielen stellen die wenigsten fanden ihr
glück in italien da suchten einfach zu
viele in italien hatten die deutschen
kein glück da hatten sie häuser also
dieser umgang mit den biografischen in
dem sinne wunden wie sie das nennt finde
ich bei mir auch zu treffen das sagt die
figur in dem buch auch dass man anders
mit seinen biografischen wunden umgeht
als noch mit anfang 20 mit anfang
zwanzig will man alles noch verändern
bewegen therapieren und ab 40 fängt man
einfach an damit so umzugehen wie es nun
einmal ist finde es sind großartige
setzte hier drin und dann zum beispiel
es geht um das verhältnis zwischen
mutter und tochter und dann sagt sie ich
gehe davon aus dass wir die erste
generation von frauen waren die machen
konnte was sie wollte das hieß aber auch
dass wir machen mussten was wir wollten
wir sollten unsere träume verwirklichen
wir mussten welche haben das scheitern
wurde uns zugestanden aber erst nach
alles wirklich alles versucht worden war
auf dem weg zum glück psychoanalyse
eingeschlossen war großartig
es war sensibel aber nicht einfühlsamen
das verstehe ich nicht finde ich schön